often i find out about weird exam
questions from comments left on my
videos and today's story starts back in
january when i noticed a handful of
comments on my short film called finding
x
saying that the video reminded them of
an essay prompt from the university of
chicago i was quite perplexed by that
and i was intrigued to know how my
fictional story about numbers could
possibly remind someone of an academic
essay prompt but what i found is that
students applying for the university of
chicago have to write a few essays and
one of them must respond to a set of
pretty weird prompts let me show you
what i mean
last year's prompts include what if the
moon were made of cheese or neptune made
of soap pick a celestial object
re-imagine its material composition and
explore the implications
they also asked what's so easy about pie
and to invent a new unit of measurement
they suggest that answers to these
questions should be about 650 words
although there isn't actually a hard
limit and you can see for each question
they credit a current university of
chicago student because they are the
ones who submit the ideas for the
questions this one quotes mark twain and
says there is no such thing as a new
idea and asks are any pieces of art
literature philosophy or technology
truly original or just a different
combination of old ideas pick something
anything besides yourself and explain
why it is or is not original going back
through the previous year's questions
they have this classic one here
find x which is the one that people had
been reminded of by my video i suppose
that writing a poem about x going off on
a journey to find their value would be
one way to answer the question but from
what i can tell the purpose of asking
these types of questions is to give
students an opportunity to share
something about themselves and their
ambitions the admissions team would have
to read thousands of these so you do
want your essay to stand out it's
tempting to read through the questions
and try to think of the most creative
and wacky ways to answer them to show
that you're thinking outside the box
and that's probably great no one wants
to sound too generic but it's probably
more important to focus on trying to
show genuine passion for your course of
study at the bare minimum you'd want to
let the admissions team know that you
aren't just applying because your
parents are forcing you to and that
secretly you'd rather be going somewhere
else or studying something different if
i were to turn my poem into an essay to
answer the prompt find x i would
probably lean in more to one of my
favorite lines which was math is not
about your value math is about
relationships
i might try to show that that line also
applies to life itself and talk about
the creative nature of math that it's
not just about finding the value of x
but about coming up with creative
relationships between numbers to
describe the world around us find x
shares the stage with so where is waldo
really
and everyone knows there are two types
of people in the world what are they
there is how did you get caught or not
caught as the case may be
and in 650 words describe a picture and
explore what it wants
no question here just a quote
don't play what's there play what's not
there
some of these questions are a little bit
absurd but this one shows some
self-awareness it says that the only
interesting answers are those that
destroy the questions
we have all heard serious questions
absurd questions and seriously absurd
questions some of which cannot be
answered without obliterating the very
question
destroy a question with your answer
for the aspiring mathematical
philosophers we have what can actually
be divided by zero
then we have the inspirational question
what's so odd about odd numbers
there is some more serious than others
but they all leave room for a lot of
creativity
beneath this one asking us to use the
power of string to explain the biggest
or smallest phenomenon
there is this one here asking us to
write an essay somehow inspired by super
huge mustard and then one which is
closer to home for me in 2015 the city
of melbourne australia created a tree
mail service in which all of the trees
in the city received an email address so
that residents could report any tree
related issues as an unexpected result
people began to email their favorite
trees sweet and occasionally humorous
letters
imagine this has been expanded to any
object tree or otherwise in the world
and share with us the letter you'd send
to your favorite my friend julian o'shea
might ace this one he's made a whole
video about emailing trees
apparently current students submit the
suggestion as a hot dog a sandwich so
often that they finally had to write a
question inspired by it a hot dog might
be a sandwich and cereal might be a soup
but is a blank a blank and i really like
this question under it here
fiction reveals truth that reality
obscures i really like it because i came
across a similar quote recently and it
helped me to put into words why i think
fiction is sometimes worth reading and
why you can learn things from books even
if they are fictional i did find some
essays written by students who are
successful in their application i
particularly like this answer posted to
collegeadvisor.com
answering a prompt about the mantis
shrimp and its amazingly complex eyes
with 16 different types of color
receptors
they ask what might the mantis shrimp be
able to see that we cannot
what are we missing
i really like this answer it is a bit
more serious but it offers some new
perspectives to both the good and bad
things that sight has given us
they talk about the discrimination that
can be attributed to our sense of vision
and of the ways that sight could be
considered limiting and they bring it
all back to ideas from the book flatland
which explores the challenge of
explaining higher realms to those who
cannot experience it the king of
pointland is so narrow-minded and
insular that he refuses to believe that
there are objects larger than his when
confronted with a square all he sees is
another point as humans our abilities
are limited as well we do not have the
innate skills of the mantis shrimp with
its 16 receptors however centuries of
innovation have made us inept to fully
perceive the skills which we are
incapable of
the mantis shrimp can see a greater
spectrum of rays and waves and possibly
some great unknown but perhaps it is
better that its abilities remain a
mystery
at this time we are probably not ready
for such visual capabilities
our current ones have already proven to
be overbearing
maybe the best things in life are not
meant to be seen because they must be
felt or understood there is a seven
percent acceptance rate at the
university of chicago and whilst these
essays make up a part of the application
they'd also be looking at grades and
other materials and they even have an
optional sat
the university of chicago is not the
only college with weird prompts here are
some from other places we have if you
could choose to be raised by robots
dinosaurs or aliens who would you pick
and why
you have just finished your 300 page
autobiography
please submit page 217.
for this one you have 150 words
take a risk perhaps you could speak from
experience or imagination in answering
you've just reached your one millionth
hit on your youtube video
what is the video about
and this one from yale what is something
about which you have changed your mind
in the last three years upon reflection
if you don't have an answer for that one
then perhaps you weren't as open-minded
as you thought you were
these essays are one way that you can
show that you are well-rounded and
interested in a variety of topics and if
you are someone who wants to foster
those interests and hobbies then check
out skillshare who have kindly sponsored
this video skillshare is an online
learning community with thousands of
online classes
it's a place to get inspired learn new
skills and put them to work in impactful
ways i was interested in joining
skillshare to learn ways to make my
content and workflow better i enjoyed
thomas frank's course mastering
productivity create a custom system that
works
it made me feel like i was about to be
entering my organized era there's a
special link down in the description and
the first 1000 people who click it will
get a one month free trial of skillshare
thanks for watching this video and a
special shout out to today's patreon cat
of the day rio jane
[Music]
you